today the college board gets a terrible
rep as the corporation that profits
hundreds of millions
off of giving students generic tests
that don't really show anything anyways
and of course their poor handling of the
online testing process this past year
with ap exams
has just made the situation even worse
but the college board actually has quite
humble beginnings with noble ambitions
so what went wrong with the college
[Music]
board
starting off with their origins the
college board was founded at columbia
university in december of 1899.
it was originally called the college
entrance examination board or
ceeb though it was founded at columbia
university
it was actually founded by
representatives from 12 different
universities
and three high school preparatory
academies see
at the time educational standards across
states and even each school
varied greatly so each college would
create their own entrance exam for
students to take
however having to take an exam for each
college application
would largely limit the number of
colleges a student could apply to
and the vastly different tests offered
by each university
made it hard to prepare for all of them
at the same time
so the ceeb set out to offer an exam
that could be used by a large number of
colleges for admission
in the early years between 1900 and 1915
the ceeb offered tests in nine different
subjects
which covered the core subjects and a
couple of languages
it wasn't until 1916 that the ceeb
decided to adopt a more comprehensive
style of the exam
that would test skills across several
subjects this
was intended to test the student's
problem solving and critical thinking
capabilities
though this decision was made with good
intent
this was the first step that started to
shift their exams in the direction of
testing how good a student was at taking
the test
as opposed to the student's mastery of
the content at the time
most of the colleges that accepted
examinations offered to the ceeb
were located in northeast however they
didn't drop their own entrance
examinations
they simply used the exams offered by
the ceeb
in conjunction with their own moving on
during world war 1 the military started
playing around with giving psychological
and intelligence tests to their soldiers
intrigued by this idea many college
admissions officials
started looking into how intelligence
testing could be used in the admissions
process
given the spike in interest the ceeb
decided that it would be a good idea to
develop their own psychological
examination
to accomplish this they called in carl
campbell who was a psychologist involved
in creating the military tests
to help them create a psychological
examination and
the result of this would be the
scholastic aptitude test or
the good old sat it had a linguistic
section and a mathematical section
and over the years a writing section has
seen some light here and there
though the test wouldn't see large scale
adoption for a few more decades
the test itself would overall be the
same starting here
the ceeb wouldn't gain full credibility
amongst educational institutions
until world war ii in world war ii the
military would hire the ceeb
to administer exams for u.s military
recruits to gauge their suitability for
skilled technical positions
and this was a turning point for the
college board if the college board was
good enough for the military
it must be good enough for college
admissions as well in 1944
only about 15 of american colleges used
the s.a.t
but this would rapidly grow over the
next two decades
and the college board would introduce ap
exams in 1955
and the psat in 1959 and by the 1960s
and 70s
the college board would grow into what
we know them as today
but in this journey where did the
college board transition from an aid to
college admissions
to just a hassle well people often point
to high exam costs
inaccessibility tests being reused bad
customer service and a good amount of
cheating as flaws with their exams
though these are legitimate issues i
actually don't think any of these are
the real problem
really i think the hate for college
board is much more deep-rooted and based
on three fundamental issues
which are timing gaming and purpose
all of the college board exams only last
a couple of hours
and everyone knows that it's not
possible to score a student's
capabilities in a subject or
in general in such a short period of
time not only this
but the short time period forces them to
emit a lot of content from the actual
class
this means that certain students can get
lucky and get something they're really
good at
while others don't the thing is block
shouldn't be a factor at all
and all content from a class should be
tested to gauge real ability
the one test and done method is simply
not indicative of one's understanding
of content and is an inherent flaw of
any such test
next up gaming the system is really easy
now i'm not talking about cheating which
is clearly also a problem
but you can easily game the system
without breaking any rules
all the questions they ask are based on
a formula and it's not that hard to
figure out what they're looking for
of course this is easier for some and
harder for others
but in general it is very possible to
just figure out their rudimentary tricks
and to get questions right without
actually having the skills to correctly
answer the question
for instance let's say college board was
asking about the main idea of this video
this is probably how they structure the
answer choices
of course they'll have two answer
choices that are clearly wrong
one of these choices will have something
to do with the title and the last choice
will be the right answer the goal of
answer choice c
is to trick someone who didn't read the
full article or just read the title
but the thing is a seasoned college
board student would know to just not
pick the answer that has to do with the
title they wouldn't need to comprehend
the article or use problem-solving
skills
they just needed to understand how the
questions are structured by the college
board to get the question right
finally and most importantly the purpose
of the college board itself
is futile the idea of a common test that
can be used to apply to many colleges
and or get college credit is appealing
but colleges around the world are
completely different and vary greatly in
terms of their teaching styles and
material
as a result the problem the college
board is trying to solve
is not even a problem it's how true
learning should work
sure it's annoying to take a test for
each college but this would make sure
people applying to each college are
actually the right fit for the college
plus this would prevent people from just
applying to every single college under
the sun
to see which ones stick as this just
wastes the time
and money of both parties involved and
these fundamental issues are what i
think people are actually frustrated
with
with more people than ever taking their
tests and the relatively new
large-scale access to social media these
fundamental frustrations
simply come to light whenever the
college board pushes back a registration
date or doesn't accommodate for a
demographic
but it wasn't really a sudden shift on
college board side that turned the
public against them
rather it's frustration with the system
itself that is surfacing more and more
luckily though with the colleges putting
a significantly smaller emphasis on
these tests
and companies putting a smaller emphasis
on college itself
it's likely that the college board will
get left behind in the next few decades
if they don't make some radical changes
to their system
but i don't think you guys would be too
sad anyways
drop a like if you agree and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you